you were a very talented woodworker and
I you I've seen the furniture this man
builds and it is absolutely gorgeous
actually I was over at your in Meghan's
place once and I was admiring what I
thought was the nicest piece of
furniture in the room and Meghan said oh
yeah Nick made that and it was
absolutely gorgeous you you have an
incredible talent for it in fact
and over the years you've been you you
do a lot of stuff from your wood shop
and you've been very public about it
I never realized until you brought it up
not long ago that working in wood
working it can be what has a sort of an
erotic element to it is that true
absolutely
I mean running one's hands sleekly over
a freshly shaped you know walnut crotch
table what's a crotch table well and
where can I get one I'm I'm glad you
asked Conan it's easy to discern when a
tree grows and splits into two limbs
that makes a natural crotch and if one
now this is true I mean this isn't your
giggling the guy who likes cats is not
giggling at this material the plant
fibers reinforce themselves to support
that that crotch in the tree yeah and so
when you slice that open if you should
be lucky enough to turn that tree in the
lumber there's there's always a really
beautiful pattern developed by that
crush and and so I mean you know just
lends itself it's it's a very sexy
velvety tactile medium if you go so far
as to make sex toys out of wood
[Applause]
if you dish ladder lacquer now go up to
at least at least 420